another legal problem for Donald Trump
that I want to briefly talk about and
then we're going to move on to other
things a federal judge has found that
Donald Trump lied under oath about voter
fraud in Georgia while trying to
overturn the 2020 election results now
we're Switching gears before we were
talking about the federal investigation
that is connected to the search warrant
at Mar-A-Lago
that's the last story this is a
different situation now Business Insider
summarizes the statement by the judge a
federal judge Wednesday said Trump lied
under oath about voter fraud claims in
the 2020 election not a big shock
Trump quote knew that the specific
numbers of voter fraud were wrong but
touted them both in court and to the
public this is per Judge David Carter
Carter made the determination in a
ruling ordering a republican lawyer to
turn over his Communications to the
January 6th committee
this goes back to December 4th of 2020
and I know many of you
remember this many of you don't many of
you have chosen to forget it and I
understand I understand why on December
4th 2020 Trump's legal team filed a
lawsuit in Georgia State Court alleging
that Fulton County miscounted thousands
of votes they also contested the state
Court's proceedings in federal court
this was one of dozens of complaints
that Trump and lawyers filed in various
courts later that month Carter wrote in
his ruling Eastman this is Trump's
lawyer Eastman said in an email
that although Trump had quote signed a
verification for the state court filing
on December 1 he had since been made
aware that some of the allegations and
evidence proffered by the experts has
been inaccurate for him to sign a new
certification with that knowledge and
incorporation by reference would not be
accurate he added the emails show that
Trump knew that the specific numbers of
voter fraud were wrong but continued to
tout those numbers both in court and to
the public this is also not the first
time that this has been suggested so
it's abundantly clear that in every
single one of these cases you have
claims that are made that normal people
who look at data and evidence doubt but
we ask ourselves
are they making these claims out of
ignorance or are they making these
claims knowing they are false claims in
order to deceive others and we don't
necessarily know right away but then
slowly but surely we come to learn that
these claims are made knowing that they
are lying in the Mar-A-Lago doj
situation did Trump believe that they
really had given back all the documents
I don't know maybe we later find out
Trump knew they had not given back all
the documents because there is a report
that he had an employee move documents
at Mar-A-Lago oh okay so he was lying he
was lying deliberately to deceive
arguably an obstructive Act
same thing here okay at the beginning of
December Trump signs off on we believe
these are the numbers of fraudulent
phony and valid votes from Georgia maybe
Trump believed it at that point in time
we then get testimony and statements
under oath that actually later on when
Trump continued to sign off on this
stuff Trump had been advised that what
he was claiming and signing off on was
not actually the truth unfortunately
Georgia state law says that the
punishment here
is up to one year in jail
and up to a one thousand dollar fine or
both this is
um uh 2020 Georgia Code title 16 crimes
and offenses chapter 10 offenses against
public administration Article 4 perjury
and related offenses and it says
punished by a fine of not more than a
thousand dollars or by imprisonment not
less than uh one not more than ten years
or both but the particulars of this uh
likely point to no more than one year in
prison uh one year in jail rather you
know there is this question is whether
as to whether the American justice
system should really assess fines as a
function of income because one of the
realities that we have in the justice
system in the United States with such
drastically different Financial
circumstances for people
are that the same five thousand dollar
fine can be a completely unpayable
bankruptcy inducing fine for many in
society and then such an insignificant
find for others in society that it does
nothing whatsoever to actually punish a
bad act and so there are countries that
do this with speeding tickets for
example we've talked about it before I
believe Norway might be one of those
countries but I don't remember
completely offhand but there is a real
question as to whether fines should be
assessed based on ability to pay with
some upper and lower limits certainly I
think that reasonable people could agree
to that so not a particularly auspicious
day yesterday for Donald Trump from a
legal standpoint but when we continue to
ask the question well but then so what
what's coming is anything coming
I think we all are in the position of
saying we don't really know
one of our sponsors today is Bluetooth a
unique online service delivering the
same active ingredients as Viagra and
Cialis in a chewable form and at a
fraction of the cost and they're giving
my audience an entire month's supply for
free so if you think you could benefit
from an extra boost of confidence when
it's time all you have to do is take a
short quiz on their website a licensed
doctor approves your prescription the
medication comes straight to your home
within days in a discrete package no
driving around to the doctor's office or
the pharmacy no waiting around no
awkward conversations with your doctor
all of Bluetooth tablets are made in the
USA the entire process is just a few
clicks go to bluetooth.com the link is
underneath this video they'll give you
an entire month's supply for free when
you use the promo code Pacman all you
have to do is pay five dollars shipping